それで慣れるという 2番目
まあこれ人格構成の仕組みということを勉強しなくちゃいけないんですね
プラクティスアゲインストラーニング
それからプロセスオブキャラクタービルディングという人格向上についても
あの えっと 知ってほしいということを
これが楽な道ですよ ハードな道じゃないんです
慣れる道はイージーウェイ
慣れてしまえば楽です
よく知ってることですね
それは 難しい嫌な学問
勉強など苦しみながらやるより
慣れてしまった方が良いと言われる場合もあります
学問の場合 見えんですよ
もうこんなのはもうもう何とかして覚えちゃえばいいんじゃないか
楽じゃないかとかね 好きな簡単な学問の場合はこの問題は起こりません
好きな学問の場合はそんなこと言わないんですけど
あえて苦しい 難しい 大事な学問の場合は
もうそんな理解しなくてどうでもいいんだから
とにかく覚えておけということで
それでみんな丸暗記するんです
それで復習する脳と心
我々の脳と心が復習して身につくんですよ
脳と心は一つじゃないんです
脳といえばほとんど肉体に関係あるもので
心といえばやっぱり人格に関係あるものなんです
脳も心も復習することでものを覚える
復習して覚えるんです
論理的な構成がなくても
復習で覚えておくことができる
大体論理的だったらもう覚えやすいんですよ
脳も心も もう心はどうちょっとないんだけど
ものすごい もう論理なんですよ
だからなんとか論理的なシステムに入れちゃえば
もうものを覚えるのは簡単ですけど
でもめちゃくちゃもう何の論理もなくても
ずっと暗記しちゃうと復習すると覚えとくんです
一旦覚えて長期記憶になってしまえば
何の苦労もなく思い出せる
だから覚えておいて 復習して復習して
長期記憶にしておく そうすると簡単に思い出せる
人の習慣 癖などもこのはっだけで出来上がる
我々の習慣というのはそういう復習なんですね
復習して もう自動的にやっちゃうんです
別に意味がないんですよ
例えば日本の習慣 アメリカの習慣とか何とか言ったって
別に何の意味もないんですよ
ただもうあまりも復習したんだから
そうでないと何かすごく居心地が悪くなる
ちょっと気分が悪くなる
習慣 癖 いろんなものを体に付くんですよ
この復習することで 皆
脳と心のこの機能を使っている
我々は誰でもこの脳と心の復習機能
覚えておきたければ復習しなさいと
でなきゃ忘れるぞと 繰り返しやりなさいと
頭の中だけでももう何回繰り返してあげないとすぐ忘れちゃう
その機能があるんです
繰り返して繰り返してリピートする
してインプットする これが動物もやってます
動物にもできる 動物は頭が悪いとか言っても
復習さればさればさせればまあやってくれますよ
だから動物の脳もできますよ
まあ人間の脳ほど優れてないでしょうに
だから人間にとってはえらい簡単なことですよ
それは一番簡単です 論理
知識などがなくてもできる
これがもうありがたいかありがたくないかわかりませんだけど
論理 知識なんかガチャガチャなくても
ただ馬鹿みたいに復習することでできるようになるんです
例えばギリシャ語なんかはもうさっぱり勉強しなくても
ギリシャ語の何か文章とかね
持ってきてずっと読み上げて読み上げて復習する
もう暗記できますよ そこで発音
発音でもちゃんと覚えてもらっちゃえば
発音を復習するとできますよ
だからこれが発音できない
あれが発音できないと言ったっても
それはないんですよ 他言語
他の言語でもちょっと復習すると
その発音できる で ローマ字で書くとTI
簡単に書けるでしょうに SS
とI書けるでしょうに
でも誰にも発音できないでしょうに SI
の発音が なんだあれとシーと言うでしょう
それ違う シーなんですよ TI
はTでしょうに パーリ語だったらTと読む T
はタイで読めますから T
と読まなくちゃいけない TT
あるのにTはないんですね
だからみんなもうシーと読むんでしょうね
私は気持ち悪くなるんですよ
意味が変わるんだからね
私も大学で教授行ったのは
ある日本の学生がアメリカに行って
もうもう遅刻したんだよ
授業に だから丁寧に教授に断らなくちゃいけないんだから
まあ遅くなってごめんなさいと言わなくちゃいけないでしょうね
それは日本語だから英語にならないですね
それで彼がメイアイシットヒアプリーズ？と聞いたんだそうです
ただ 教授いきなりプリーズドンと言ったんだそうです
この子は驚いちゃったと
メイアイシットと私はここでうんこしてもいいんでしょうかということでしょうね
これはダメでしょうに
いくら日本人だといっても教室の中で
だからメイアイシットヒアと言ったらもうよかった
だからシットシットっていうのは
他の人のは意味が違うんですよ
だから あ これは日本人にできないんだっていうのはちょっと怠けなんですよ
できますよ ちょっと復習しなくちゃできないだけ
それだけのことで だって日本で歌う演歌を歌う犬もいますよ
だったらなんで普通の方々にできないんですかね
テレビで見たんですよ
結構歌うんですよ 聞いてはいられませんだけど
えらい可愛いんですよ
とにかく とにかく音楽に合わせて吠えるんです
ウォウウォウウォウとかね
だから本物の歌よりはこれがすごく可愛いことは可愛いんです
そういうことで復習しちゃうとできるんです
あれはドイツ語のね ウムラウトとかね
何でしたっけ？だからあの理論知識なくてもできる
しかし 理論 知識 理解などがあるとさらに楽に覚えられる
復習して覚えるものは
ちゃんと論理的にも理解しているんだったら
ものすごく楽になるんです
もうあの労働はもう本当にもう 10 分の1に減っちゃうんですよ
わけもわからないことを覚えておこうと思って
結構苦しいし よく意味をわかるともうすごい楽々に覚えてしまう
マインドコントロールにも使える
問題は この復習機能がマインドコントロールにも使っている
あれ 何かに復讐しちゃうと
人間っていうのは自動的にロボットみたいにやりますから
この品物を買っちゃえばかっこいいやと
頭いい人はみんな買ってるんだと
何回も繰り返して言うと買っちゃうんです
買って役に立たないものを買ったんだけど
私もなかなか頭のいい人間のうちの一人だと
だってあるでしょうね
金持ちの仲間に入るためにはこれこれやればいいってこと
それで苦労してそういうクラブに入るんですよ
ゴルフクラブに入っていると
なんと会員になってるとかね
外車に乗ってるとかね
そんなものでも金持ちの仲間に入っているとかね
そういうものをマインドコントロールでみんな言って言って言って
こちら聞いて聞いて聞いて
復讐するんですよ 復讐の場合は自分がやるならばマインドコントロールになりませんよ
これ 世界が復讐させるでしょ
させるでしょうね あれがマインドコントロールなんです
まあ危ないところもすごくありますよ
だから嘘でも何回何回繰り返して言うと事実になるという話でしょうしね
政治家は政治世界ではもう堂々と使ってます
全く根拠のない嘘をずっと言いっぱなしで
マスコミでも事実バレるとマスコミにも脅しかけて
ただ 日本で堀江さんというのはすごい悪人になったのは
ずっとマスコミが言いっぱなしであって
あの人何が悪いことしたかと
全然もう記録も何もないんですけど
だからフジテレビはもうネクタイを締める人にあげると
とんでもないんだと  IT 関係の関連のことに
これはニュースだよと
マスコミだよと言いながら
IT 関連の人にあげる
なぜかというと ネクタイつけてるんですよ
これですごい大事です
で バリバリなんとかもう大胆なことをやりたいと思う人をやらせませんという
まあそういう その時でも
みんな一斉にあの若者の悪口を言う
昔もあったんですよ あの野球のあれ
野村さんの奥さん 何でしたっけ？野村幸
もうテレビ朝つけて もう夜までもうずっと野村幸の悪口を言うという偉い偉大なるマスコミですよ
そんな素晴らしいものを堀江さんに買われちゃうとたまったもんじゃないんですよ
あんな悪人に だからあの連中は
私はもう地球上からもうもう綺麗に掃除して
宇宙に捨てちゃえばいいと思ってますけど
それ私一人だけなんですけど
そう思ってるんだから
あまり心配しないでください
で ずっと我々に間違ってる情報を
汚い情報を格好つけて復讐させる
そうすると我々は知らないうちにマインドコントロールされちゃう
だから復讐だったら自分でやれと
自分で選んで そうするとマインドコントロールされません
事実無根のもの 迷信 根拠のない信仰
噂なども心に植え付けることができる
これってよくやってるでしょうに
キリスト教でもないのに
神様を信じるっていうのは
結婚式ならカ n 教会でやらなくちゃいけない
何なんですかね あれは
キリスト教の人が行くところでしょうね
ハワイにでも行って 日本のホテルでもどこでもチャペルというものがあるんですよ
あれ 完全たるマインドコントロールなんですよ
そういうことをやらなかったら
結婚式を挙げなかったということになるんです
神社でやったら あれは結婚式じゃないんですね
一応神社でもそういう用意はありますけど
結婚式の だって日本人なのに
なんで神社に行って結婚式しないのかというと
日本人もわからない マインドコントロールされています
だから面白いんですよ
ハワイなんか行っても
神父さんでも何でも 誰かがバカが来て
なんとか読み上げて ああ
なんて美しい結婚式だと
あの文章を読み上げる人って何者かわからないでしょうに
まあそれが一番軽いマインドコントロールで
もっとひどいマインドコントロールいっぱいあります
今日はテーマじゃないんだから
まあそこら辺でやめます
それで何でしたっけ？訂正
改良 変えることなどが難しい
これで復讐して身についちゃうと
それから変えることなんか難しい難しい
そうやって伝統的に皆さんはマインドコントロールされているものに
私が悪口を言ったっても
私はすごい悪口だと非難しているんだと
日本日本人をと思っちゃう
そこまで行くんです だから変えることは難しいんです
覚えた 習っただけで トレーニングウィズコーション
何でしたっけ？復習の注意
だから注意しなくちゃいけないんですよ
覚えた 習っただけで 知識
理解 能力 才能は発揮しない
よく覚えておいてください
何か覚えただけで能力開発ありえません
理解ができたとありえません
犬にもできるんだから
覚えるぐらいはね 慣れるぐらいは犬にもできるんだからね
それで立派になりません
何を習っているか 覚えているかを見極めておかないと大変なことになる
我々は毎日何を習っているのか
何を復習しているのかということははっきり見極めておかないと
最初から 気がつかないうちに危険な習慣が身についていることになりかねません
これ 結構あるんでしょうね
時々ちょこちょこっと麻薬使ったりとか
友達と一緒に まあ友達一緒だから
もうなんとか悪いことでもあんまり気にしないでやったりして
それから知らないうちにもうそこにもう漬け状態になっていて
離れなくなるんです だからすごく気をつけなくちゃいけない
この復習機能は もう頭いらんことだからね
考えることも必要じゃない仕事だからね
習う前にそれは善か悪か
役に立つか立たないかはかを調べるべきなのです
だから 何か習う前に まず調べておく
ただ やったことがないんだからやってみようはダメなんです
やったことがなくても
それが無意味だったらやるなよ
それからの 私にはあんたやったことないんだから
スキーすればどうでしょうかと
そしたら私は面白い考え方だなと
まあ子供がその提案出したらやっぱりやっちゃいますけど
まあ子供でしょうに で
まあ転がっちゃってもどったとしても
恥ずかしいでもなんでもないんだから
これまあかなりかなりプロみたいな能力もあるある人なんですね
どうでしょうかと やっぱり私はやったことはないし
じゃあやめると やめたことでまだ生きてるんです
もし もしその友達に乗せられてやったならば
もういないと思います
えらい険しいところからもうスピードでやってるんですよ
だから何かやる 習う前に必要かないか調べた方がいいんです
それでまた続きですね
トレーニングウィズコーションの悪いものを習ったら
決して習わないことにする
誘惑に負けない勇気が必要ですね
それには悪いものだったら
もう決して間違って冗談ででもやらない方がいいんですよ
これ復習だからね 慣れることだから
まあ危ない 覚えてしまえばもうどうなるかわからない
自分がロボットになるんだから
すごい気をつけなくちゃいけない
それにはちょっと勇気が必要ですよ
みんな誘惑するんだからね
もう社会で誘惑するものは全部
ほとんど悪いことに誘惑する
良いことには誘惑しない
麻薬 酒 たばこ 世間話 無駄
無駄な遊びなどには慣れない方が良いに決まってる
例えばこういうものによく慣れたもんやと
私は自慢できますかね
麻薬にたばこに酒にあーもうもうよく慣れましたよと
腕が上がってるんだと
この自慢できない無駄話
余計な遊び 怠けることや物事に真面目に取り組めないことなどに性格的に慣れてしまう場合があるのです
それから我々は知らん知らんうちに怠けに慣れてしまう
いつでもどうすれば怠けるのか
そればっかり考えちゃう
それもある それ性格的に
怠けに怠ける それからまあ大したことない
あれもこれも大したことはない
あれもどうったことないとか
自分の毎日の仕事をやらなくちゃいけないことについて
あまり真面目に取り組めないんですよ
まあ手抜き 料理にしたっても
掃除機掃除したっても
仕事にしたっても どんどんどんなものにも手抜きになるんですよ
自分が病気になって薬を飲まなくちゃ
まあ 1 2 3 日毎に一回でもいいんじゃないかとかね
手抜くんですよ だから
そういうものにも絶対慣れてはいけないんですね
そこら辺で終わると エデュケーションアンドトレーニング
これで両方合わせるんです
で 慣れるということを説明して終わった
結論は書いて忘れちゃった
結論書くのは まあ一応結論は言いました
これ犬にもできるんだと
あまりシャレになれんと
だから学問よりも気をつけた方がいいんです
何に慣れるのかと また
慣れるということは すべての生命にある
この復習機能 これ 肉体にもあるし
脳細胞にもあるし 心にもあります
なんで全部入ってるのか
面白いんですよ 肉体の復習でも慣れてしまう
脳細胞を復習すると それに慣れてしまう
心も復習で慣れてしまうんです
だからかなり大事な現象なんです
合わせてみるとどうですか？学問には習うことは欠かせないものです
これはもう欠かせないものですよ
知識能力がない無知な人にも習えば覚えておけばなんとか通れる
知識人にはなれないので
なんとか通れるが なんとか通れますよ
頭が悪くても やっぱりもう慣れてしまえば
あ あいつはわかってるってことになるんですけど
それで知識人にはならないんですよ
丸暗記だけが学問ではないことを理解しておかなくちゃならないんですね
しかし 丸暗記だけは学問じゃない
全く英語できない人にも
どこかで講演するということはできますよ
スピーチコンテストありますからね
あのスピーチコンテストでみんな見事な英語でやってますよ
子供たちとかね あれで英語できると思いますかね？全然できない
ただ 自分のスピーチの原稿をもう読める人に読んでもらって
それがもう聞いて聞いて
聞いて聞いて聞いて復習するんです
そこでスピーチコンテストの時は
かなり綺麗な英語で綺麗なイントネーションで綺麗なアクセントで喋るんですよ
それで審査員もいちんち点数入れたりする
意味がないと思いますけど R
の回りが良かったとか
すごくアクセントの置き所が正しかったとか
だからこのそうやってなんかできそうな面をして抜けるんですよ
習うこと気をつけてほしい
習っただけで覚えただけで知識人じゃありません
理解ができるだけでも
知識人なんて理解ができるだけでも知識人にならない
では 理解だけどうですかね
理解はしている でも知識人じゃないんです
なぜならば 必要なデータを覚える
必要なものを習っておくことも大事ですよ
だから勉強はわかったんだけど
何も覚えてない だったら知識人じゃないでしょうね
勉強は覚えたんだけど
何もわかってない 知識人じゃないでしょ
だから理解して覚える人のみ知識人なんです
ちゃんと私は言ってることややこしいんだけど
ポイントは単純ですよ
これ私の喋り方なんですね
悪いまずいのは まあ誰かに代筆で喋ってもらうしかないんですけど
で 先生おっしゃったことはよく理解できたと
これ何をおっしゃったんですか？と
ちょっと覚えてないんだと
役に立たない 知識人じゃない
それで先生おっしゃったことを全部覚えちゃったと
それで理解した 全然理解
わけもわからないんだけど
どちらでも同じなんです
だから理解することと必要なデータを覚えておくという両方必要なんです
今はこちらに関係ないんだけど
また一つ経典を思い浮かんだんで
頭の中で頭混乱しているんで
今の今 経典なんか思い浮かんじゃうと話しなくなっちゃいますけど
まあ一応言います 思い浮かんだものは
ある日 帝釈天がこの神様の王様なんですよ
あの大体来るのは夜なんですね
来てお釈迦様のところにそっと来たんです
もう神様の王様だから
もう大々で来るわけにはいきませんし
で お釈迦様と話しているんです
お釈迦様もなんかいろいろ説法しているんです
本人がいろいろ質問すると
あ これはこういうことで
こういうことで こういうことなんです
それであの お釈迦様のお部屋ではなくて
別の外で どこかで目連尊者が禅定に入っていたんですよ
で 禅定に入っていたんだから
この神様の声は聞こえるんですよ
お釈迦様の言葉も聞くお釈迦様の神様に神様に聞こえる波長で喋ってるでしょうに
で なんで聞くことになったのか
人のこの話をイースロッピング
英語で日本語で何て言いますか
もう勝手に聞くこと 人を話してる
えっ？盗み聞き えっ？別に盗み聞き盗聴したわけじゃないんですよ
なんで気になったかというと
お釈迦様は何か説明すると
この帝釈天がでっかい声で
もう響き声でよくわかりました
まあシャドーと言うんですよ
なるほど よくわかりました
でお釈迦様は普通の声でしゃべる
お釈迦様はだいたい聞く人以外は聞こえないんで
お釈迦様の声はかなりこのボリュームコントロールはできていたんです
外に漏れない しかし 中の人々にはみんなに聞く
聞け 聞こえる 帝釈天はそれできん
もうド派手な声で その波長があまりも厳しくするんだから
目連尊者の禅定を心を通して聞こえちゃって
どういうことかというと
これはあいつの声だと声知っている
あのもう作家の声でしょ
これはと で あ お釈迦様が説法しているんだと
言ってもお釈迦様は二人に三人目
聞こえないでしょ 大作戦のこのバカでかい声ばっかし聞こえて
それでさっさともう短い時間でこの人は天国に帰ったんです
帰ったら目連尊者が考えるんですよ
あのバカがお釈迦様におっしゃったこと
本当にわかったんですかと
あまりにもわかったわかった
よくわかりました なんていうことですか
驚いちゃうんだからね
あいつは覚えてるんですか？お釈迦様が教えたことは
その 2つ気になるんですよ
本当にわかったか 本当にわかったなら覚えてるでしょうし
覚えていなかったら意味がないでしょうし
だから昔 仏教ではわかって覚えておけ
覚えたならばわかっておけ
理解しておけ どちら両方必要なんです
でないと完全危ないんです
それで目連尊者が天国に行ったんです
天国に行ったら 彼もちょっと隙間を作って人間
お釈迦様に会ったんだから
もうまだ遊び始めているんですね
他の神々と いうともう目連尊者が来るのを見て
ああ よくまあお姉ちゃんだからね
彼にも彼にしてみれば
目連尊者はね あ 目連尊師がよく来てくれましたと
これで天国っていいところでしょとかね
だから森の木の下にいると
いる目連尊者でしょうね
どうですかね 私の宮殿とかね
これはもう小さな小さなこのクーターガラという
この別個別別々な家みたいなものを
巨大な宮殿の中にも 1万以上あるんだそうですね
天国だから まあ別に その中でまた天女たちもいろいろ住んでいて
一個一個でももう一つの宮殿みたいなもんで
そういうお城なんですね
これでこれぐらいありますよ
この窓はこんなもんかと案内するんですよ
で 目連尊者はね あのね
興味ないんだと 私は聞いたのは
あんたはお釈迦様に会って説法したでしょ？聞いたでしょ？あれ
私が教えてちょうだいと
目連さん それ知りたいんですよ
自分は大作の声聞いたんだけど
お釈迦さんの声聞かなかったんだから
私が教えてちょうだいよ
で 大作戦はね この天女たちはね
この辺でこういう色の天女でいますよ
見てくださいと すごい綺麗でしょうとかね
ごまかす 一歩でもごまかす
言わない まあせっかく来たんだから
ちょっと見学して楽しめましょうと
だからお互い同じ仏教の仲間だから
まあお互いにいろいろからかってるやってるだけの話で
とにかく大作戦はもう言わないことにする
もしかすると目連尊者をごまかしていた
からかっていた可能性もあります
ちょっとからかってやるぞと
それで目連尊者はもう我慢できで
自分の親指であの巨大なお城をガタガタガタガタガタガタ震えちゃったんです
あんたが言ってるこの偉い偉い宮殿ってこれですかと
自分の足でこれですかねと親指だけ刺しちゃうと
これはグッチャグチャグッとグッと揺れ始めたんですね
そうするともう大地震でみんなもう天女たちやらもう何千
何万もいるんだから みんな驚いちゃって
ものすごい怖くなっちゃって
それにはもう大作も参ったんですよ
もうどうすることもできなくなっちゃって
言ったらはいはい わかりました
わかりました もう教えてあげますと
それでやっと教える気になったんです
だったら教えてくださいと言うと
見事に覚えていたんです
全部 あれ 覚えてないふりをしたんですよ
これも可愛いんですよ
仏教の世界ではね 私はこれを知ってることもしないしね
たとえ大作戦でもなんか覚えてないふりをして
あんなことを逆いじめやったところで
もうはいはい わかりました
わかりました 負けた 負けた
もう教えてあげますと言うと
全部教えてあげたんです
言ったらそれで終わらない
目連尊者はさっとお釈迦様のところに行ったんです
行ってまあ お釈迦様は大作戦に説法なさったんですけど
まあこういうこういう内容ですか
内容ですかと 正しいですかと聞いたら
うん その通りだと あの人はちゃんと覚えているんだと
いうことで その経典終わっちゃうんですよ
だから私はなんでその物語を言ったんでしょうかというと
物語で終わりませんよ
経典は ちゃんとあの大作戦の教えた内容はすごい難しいんで
それは仏教の真理ですからね
エピソードは全然関係ないんです
ちょっとエピソード内容難しいんだから
エピソードも入れちゃって
ちょっと読みやすくしているだけ
えーと その時でも理解しただけではダメ
覚えておいただけでもダメ
覚えて理解するか 理解して覚えるか
どちらかしなさいと 両方必要ですということなんです
で 慣れてしまうことに気が取られると
理解することは無視するので注意する必要があります
まあ丸暗記すること 慣れることばっかりやっちゃうと
なんか理解することができなくなるんですね
だから注意してほしい
あまりにもものを覚えていくと
置くとインスピレーション
新しいアイデアなどにの障害にもなるから注意するんですよ
覚えることだけしちゃうと
インスピレーション アイデアが出てこないんです
ありがたい例っていうのは日本人の英語能力なんですね
覚えることだけはもう世界一
単語を覚えるわ 辞書を丸暗記するわ
文法は覚えるわ しかし喋れない
喋るとても暗記した文章で喋ろうとしてるんですよ
もうそれではもう一行で終わっちゃいます
会話は 相手はどう反応するかわからないでしょうね Howare
youと なんとかこちらは暗記していますよ Fineandyou
それを覚えてるんですよ
でも実際英語を喋るんだ Fineandyou
と聞かない 何言うかわかんない
その人は 例えば普通はHowareyouと思うけど Howdo
youと言うでしょうに
だからまあ暗記だけでは使えないんですよ
それで暗記することに時間取られると
自分の能力を追求しちゃうと吸収されると理解することはできなくなるんです
あの 私のコンピューターの英語の勉強する
ちょっとプログラム入れてあって
あれ 私はゲームの代わりにやってますけど
だって結構負けますよ
あの単純な英語なんですけど
それでもう一人男の子が来ていて
その時ちょっとそれやっていて
で 何かこれって答え何？と私に言うと
あの子は簡単に言うんですよ
これやと あれ なんで私知ってるのか
それで私はこれどちらでももうどちらかわからないんだよと
それでこれですと だから
あのね これは使いません
こんなこと英語では 誰も英語喋る
そんなこと使いませんよ
おかしいやと で 言ってそこは OK したらやっぱり OK なんですよ
ああ そういうことかと
でも私としては負けるの楽しいんですよ
まあだからこの それちょっとした例で覚えるだけはするんだけど
もう立派に覚えるんだけど
結局使えなくなっちゃうんですね
だからインスピレーションがなくなっちゃうんですね
しかし 習うより慣れるではなく
習うことも慣れることも両方が必要です
だからこの これは慣れることに悪口言ったんだけど
両方は必要なんです 注意するところがあるだけで
不可分離だと思った方が良い
うん